MATT MURRAY GETS THE START IN
OUGH HIS
FIGHT.
LAINE NEARLY CAME UP WITH.ON LO.
TRYING TO GET OUT OF
POEHLING AND IT WAS BROKEN
UP. BOARDS AND DOWN THE ICE.
ICING CALL AGAINST COLUMBUS.
THEN THEY REALLY SHOWED A
LOT OF CHARACTER.
I THOUGHT THEY PLAYED MUCH
BETT
EDMUNDSON WAI
>> John: LAINE GOES AFTER
PITLICK WILL GET IT BACK
CKTHE BOARDS AND DOWN THE ICE.K.
NIKE QUIST CONNECTS WCING.
[ Whistle ]
BRENENST.
BROKEN UP.
NI
CHINAKHOV
NOW BRENDAN GALLAGHER PLAY
IT IS OFF THE GAS.ITH THE SAVE!
AN
REBOUND CLEARED TO THE
POINT.E IS PUTTING ON A
CLINIC THIS FIRST PERIOD.
THISIS LEGS!
THE MANIT AND DIVING BACK WAS
ROMANOV.
HE BLOCKED THE PLANEUTRAL ZONE U
CAN HUNT DOWN THE PUCK AND.T UPE
CREASE.ED.
KULAK INTO THE CORNER.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU'RE GOING
WELL YOUT CENTRE.AUSE THIS PUCKS
GOING TO HIT HIS PAD.
HE MISSES THE PUCK HERE.
OOP!
BUT IS ABLE TO WHAT?
MARTIN St. LOUIS SAYING
DURING OUR COMMERCIAL BUE.
AND CLAGUE FORCED BACK TO PETRYR
BJORKSTRAND WILL STOP TO
PLAY IT IN FRONTVANS ON IT THROH
CENT
UP OVER THE GLASS AND OUT OF
PLAYN.
THAT ONE GOT AWAY FROM
BOQVIST AND DOWN THE ICE.
MERZLIKINS WILL FIELD THE
PUCK TO GAVRIKOV.
AND INSTEAD OF FIELDER IT.
PITLICK LEFT IT FOR PET SO PATIS
HE'S BEEN THIS AFTERNOON.
THE NET.LUE JACKETS'
ZONE.
LEFT IT FOR BYRON.EVANS HANDS IR
CHIAROT.
BACK FOR PETBUS.
SILLINGER TO THE BOX.
CANADIENS WILL GET A POWER
PLAY.
>> Greg: AND JUST BEFORE HOFFMA.
UP THROUGH
ZACH WERENSKI TO VORACEK.
THIRD TIME WITH IT NOW.
WITH AN UNBELIEVABLE SAVE.
THE CANADIENS SHOOT AWAY THE